I actually never thought I would be in
LA working into pure film I thought my
whole career would be theater in New
York I mean I really was like I'm gonna
be broke but I'm gonna be happy and I'm
gonna be really tired and I'm gonna do
theater for my whole life because I love
it so so much so I I was just as shocked
to you know audition for my first pilot
season right out of college and luckily
booked a pilot which was great and then
I met Adeline ball on an audition for
True Blood and passed Anna Paquin in the
hallway I remember they're like you're
testing for sick you you're testing for
sick and I was like oh my god I'm so
excited and they're like they're testing
against one other girl but I was like oh
my gosh who was gonna be and I was
straight out of college with like no
credits and then in the hallway Anna
Paquin and I pass each other and I was
like oh but it was so nice to have that
audition go well and then have a lowball
offer me the part of Sarah Newlin for
the second season so that was pretty
cool that that worked out that way when
did you find out you got that second
role was there like a period of you know
disappointment that you didn't get the
role of Sookie and then all of a sudden
it was a surprise that he didn't Sarah
for season two yes that's exactly what
happened and so funnily enough my best
friend from high school was living in LA
at the time and I was in New York and
she was a stand-in
she was Anna Paquin stand-in on True
Blood and she calls me up and she goes
Anna there's the show that's so right
for you and this character that Anna
Paquin is slaying you would have been so
and I was like don't even talk to me I
tested against her word that role and I
was so sad I luckily booked a pilot that
didn't get picked up to Syria that same
season but then flash-forwards first
season is over it's a huge hit and then
my agent calls me and he was like I have
a little bit of a surprise for you I'm
Alan Ball called and he really wants you
to come be a part of the series in a
different role but something that
things that you could totally kill and
he wants to talk to you on the phone so
I was freaking out jumping up and down
talk to Alan ball on the phone and
realize like like things happen for a
reason you know I I got to do Equus on
Broadway opposite Daniel Radcliffe and I
wouldn't have been able to do that had I
been cast as Sookie so I started to
realize that there are certain things
that happen the way that I was supposed
to and not to beat yourself up too much
because that was never my role to begin
with that was always hers and one thing
led to another and then I got to to act
with her and so it was really great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]